to send a meeting invitation start by
clicking the schedule a meeting
button the first part is very similar to
a standard meeting invitation enter your
information including optional location
of message and move on to adding
participants if you've connected your
calendar and opted to have your contacts
as well you'll be able to search your
contact
list moving on to step three this is the
part that's different from a standard
meeting
invitation rather than select one time
and hope that everyone can make it we're
going to propose multiple
times since I've set my meeting duration
at 30 minutes when I select a full block
like this what I'm saying is that I'm
available for any 30 minute time slot
within this block
in the preview pane we can see what it
will look like for our
invitees you'll note that they don't see
any of my meeting events all they see
are the times that I've proposed is
available finally I select if I want
tungle to send the meeting invitation
for me or if I'd like a private URL to
include in in a current email or Skype
conversation
I click create
invitation and I'm done